[Music]
so this week we've got shadow boyfriend
sexy whoopsy and obsessed to impress
like he's not real boy he follows you
around like this oh oh really attack
it's an extremely tan man that can't let
you go know that your first guess was
right
Oh fact that it's not a real what's our
first guest but it's a fake boyfriend
he's not even real yeah so this Japanese
company has created a device again oh
man it again a lot of Japanese people
yeah and you can make money doing that
oh man I would love to have a job where
it's gotta hug people for money dude I
you would be rich you give really good
hugs as much as I [ __ ] hate you I hug
from the heart good hug yeah that's our
dope man you grew up in a church man
everybody hugs dudes like it's like it's
like that way you could show if somebody
gives me a bad hug I want them to get
the [ __ ] away from me hug
yeah just Mariel used to give really
really bad hugs why why I think she just
didn't like people touching her uh so
she didn't like it and so I just think
one of those like like flimsy like that
yes yeah she would do that
so like this really yeah he's gotten way
better to me it depends there's like a
quick like hey what's up hey what's up
see you later
or it's like that was a great [ __ ]
conversation we had a moment yeah I
think there's a difference there's a
difference like I saw you yesterday
guys anyway so the Japanese company here
they've created a device that projects
on the window curtains this guy that's
like a boyfriend of yours like this is
mainly for women who live alone so they
can deter perverts from like creeping up
on their windows there's that many
pervert problems a clip you're why
Japanese people are [ __ ] pervert you
know what's crazy in China they have
like a legit shortage of women right
like you're a man to woman ratio it was
ridiculous but they're still not doing
much it's the culture what you know like
there's this what's that one movie that
we're watching that one Korean one that
did the Chinese people aren't that
perverted
handmaiden so that the same director
Chung Parktown Wu he directed old boy
and then there's like a crazy pervert a
movie that's really good and I was like
what the [ __ ] like almost all of Asian
culture came from China at one point
right and it passed through Korea Japan
so I'm like how come there's this crazy
Japanese perversion even a little bit of
Korean perversion but not so much in
China and I looked it up
so China used to be hella perverted too
and they had hella like old-school like
script porno and all that [ __ ] but when
Confucius came he banned all of that but
in the Taoists culture they have their
own Kama Sutra they have their own like
keep jacking off right entire about the
bus than that but then squeeze your
console you don't it has it you read all
that I read all of that like you know
all those places okay the Jade anal
beads that was in that [ __ ] oh yeah
those are Chinese you know it's not you
know it goes in the world China vagina
beads Dover Chinese things and I'm like
what the [ __ ] that's all like Confucius
came in then he [ __ ] everything he's
Lee [ __ ] that up but then when all the
when all of that those teachings went
into Japan so Japan was like we'll take
a little bit of Confucius but we gotta
keep our culture pure so we're keeping
the perversion yeah I wonder what
happens at this company like let's say a
girl comes up right she's like busted
and she goes I need one of these like
pervert go away faint and they're like
listen you don't need it
no matter how ugly a girl is there's
always a uglier guy that's that's into
it all cuz there's still boobs and maybe
she's a butterface oh yeah maybe butter
faces are not ugly well that's the
that's why they're called butter faces
that's what I'm sayin but her face means
everything is great but so she's now
look at the whole creature that's funny
Vanessa and I saw butter face yesterday
we were driving by and we both looked at
we're like oh and then we as we drove by
we saw her place when it was like one of
those moments
that's all sad all right show you guys
this clip of this device here that
projects a shadow boyfriend on the
window let's see that [ __ ] [ __ ] her
the shadow boyfriend [ __ ] does he do
the same thing every time though cuz
they're gonna catch up they have a
different they just copy the home alone
good that should be so funny it's like a
shadow boy everybody's slapping her
[Laughter]
vacuuming such a lie oh he's dancing -
it's pretty good
wow those are really good though I
thought I was gonna be robotic look I
thought it was gonna be them making out
and [ __ ] he's a weird guy cuz that
means he's set up lighting for the
shadow to be that strong yeah
directly in front sure she has a
boyfriend but he's a [ __ ] weird it's
into it and why are you air guitar and
why the lights so bright in the house
they definitely have to do like
different like package with like
domestic violence package there's like
different ones like she's getting
dragged across the floor and after she
gets that star they start kissing each
other making out and telling he still
loves her you know and they have to be
an audio package with it - yeah like I
still love you even though I hit you I
hit you because I love you or it could
it could be where she's abusing the
boyfriend and then the pervert feels sad
and then he calls the police yeah
there's that one too
okay then the owner of that thing is
gonna have please come all the time
oh there could be another one too where
she's getting a [ __ ] what's it called
rotisserie you know I mean by two guys
and she's like rotating around the day I
don't know actually I think the perverts
gonna like that you schmuck oh I forgot
what the product was for I was there for
me
it's pervert deterrent the brainstorming
session of the product company I
probably gotten fired in the first day
what if the pervert deterrent is like
she takes off her clothes [ __ ] dick
yeah like things fall out yeah she's all
sexy and then she turns to the side as a
[ __ ] boner yeah there's a hard dick
like [ __ ] balls falling out of her
[ __ ] titties oh my god yeah she gets
hairier shall be dumb she becomes a wolf
she turns into a [ __ ] monster [ __ ]
like a hunchback or then she turns into
a grandma like you know the the red lady
the red wizard on [ __ ] Game of
Thrones you know how she's like an old
lady in the marriage
dude she takes off her bra and I think
they're big she takes off and it just
goes boom yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] she takes
her underwear off I just want to see the
pervert just like look you got it just
go this is [ __ ] throwing up and it's
binocular perverts like hiding in trees
and it's all falling out of that's
exactly what that series in Austin
Powers yeah creepy creepy stalkers as
prisons just gonna have like the entire
day right that's what I'm thinking
they'd be across-the-street neighbor
good night perverts don't work all night
so this is just a bunch of regular
people like the daytime perverts cuz
these are for the night sign is it
appear
I think the a.m. shifts hanging out in
the do you guys remember the train there
were women only yeah cuz then they get
groped and stuff talking about that
Japan is one of the city or Tokyo is one
of the cities in the world that has the
most women living alone so and that's
why they created this product but it's
not up for sale yet so I don't know how
much it's worth
speaking of perverts I was in Cape Town
this guy walked into this lady's
restaurant whipped out his dick it
started spinning around it's interesting
he's walked in he just went so the like
the brutal movie where he [ __ ] whips
is with circle why does Hebrew know but
it was a [ __ ] so in charge of mind just
opened up this like small little spot
next to our saucer spot that have yeah
and then she just come he comes out and
she's like asking us to come over like
it was me and a few guys or like why
because it was like a creepy guy in then
he just whips out of thickest our spoke
is spinning it around and then he just
walks on out and it runs onto the middle
of street uh was he hard no he just had
a really big one all right why would he
might have had like you might have had
like I didn't take a good look at it it
might have been like one of those like
half chubs but he was like oh yeah cuz
some people get really horny or like
they enjoy flashing well what did it do
and sometimes we do spin it gets harder
to I would oh how hard you have to spin
it you know some experience it's like a
like a centrifuge you know like yeah was
she alone were there customer she was in
the store by herself at the time and it
was just that guy and then he just well
I think he was like on some weird chick
she should have thrown that beating bop
hot [ __ ] stone [ __ ] out his dick man
burn that [ __ ] off that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
weird dude alright for our next story
there's this Texas mom that posted on
Facebook a photo of her son and the
shirt that he wore to school he was just
she was apologizing to the school saying
I'm sorry I had no idea
Anthony wore this to school [ __ ]
Anthony it comes out I'm gonna show you
a clip of that he's always told me
recording her son and how he explained
what he thought this shirt what oh and
this was one of the shirts in it I
thought he was like McDonald's
how cute yours stop your anything No
it's a girl's legs spread open
that's budget awesome why would he have
that shirt without his mom knowing he
said somebody says on me when in some
closet maybe it was like they received a
box from a friend just clothes like
hand-me-down clothes and so she didn't
look through the box he just pulled out
a shirt that makes that it was through
it on she didn't realize until you got
home cuz she even asked him in the video
did your teachers say anything he was
like no they thought it was McDonald too
[ __ ] man if I was his age I know
what the [ __ ] that is how old is he
elementary school so I believe I believe
them cuz if you knew what it is I don't
think he'd be dumb enough to wear it
that's good cuz if he's dumb enough to
wear it back home mm-hmm yeah you
wouldn't want a mom to see you at school
not at home yeah the kids are really bad
liars he does not look like he's lying
whatsoever he now he knows what it means
that's not the McDonald's logo and those
are [ __ ] high heel shoes are you just
trying to like glance at it just like
really quickly I read all those we
talked about I was like oh that's your
Japanese side coming out jealous I
unbelievable I could I didn't get it at
first and you guys started laughing and
I felt dumb because I'm like wait what
the hell's happening and then it looked
and I saw the [ __ ] platform heels
that come fuck-me pumps I know cuz
remember that brand that sweat brand
were there two girls that are sitting
next to Papa Cape Kiba yeah and it looks
like a and I'm like I knew that [ __ ]
work was too naked girls since the
beginning of time Facebook post I went
viral which is now private because I I
can't show you guys that actual post but
a lot of people were saying that they
thought it was McDonald's to it they're
like oh man I wouldn't have noticed
either I've been craving McDonald's so
bad yeah looking at this story kinda
reminded me of so none of the teachers
got him you got him like caught it or
nothing no it was just a mom pose
like a public apology I just tell her
friends and then it ended up going viral
English speaking a fast food real quick
who's the one that said that Yoshino yo
was good here in Japan it's amazing yeah
in Japan somebody said it was good here
no one's talking Yoshida for the first
time after like X amount of years I
thought one of you guys said that it was
like it wasn't that bad here it is
disgusting is that this guy a neon
[ __ ] vest it's not disgusting it's
it's not good no I just assumed that it
was gonna be like wama ground you want
me no no the one bit I went to was clean
as [ __ ] which door did you get though
the [ __ ] new lobster stew okay listen
to me I got two things I got the lobster
stew be real quick it's definitely downs
fillet fish is amazing and I had the
beef ball so it was a combo but the beef
halls not bad right that [ __ ] was
disgusting okay it depends on what it's
a little grated so the one I went to was
like the new one in Montebello right
across from the for the theater it's
like brand-new look at it open there but
it depends on where you go through i I
was how often is it that I eat a food I
don't finish it like I did not finish
that [ __ ] dude I grew up on that beef
ball my dad is to buy that [ __ ] for me
and I'll put it on the bottom of my
backpack and carry it around I love you
but your words with food don't mean [ __ ]
because of your upbringing and your mom
not yeah remember that tied joints
me up you're like yo this is Bob I've
been into it I was like what's up [ __ ]
he [ __ ] over time macaroni and gravy
er yeah crazy [ __ ] that is delicious I
was like well when did you eat this
because well after I you know dropped
Hillary and I came after a rape in high
school it was really good for our last
story there was this man that robbed a
bank and threw the money that he stole
over the fence into Taylor Swift's Oh
oh [ __ ] because he wanted to impress her
so he knew he knew her house too he
wants to show her he's gonna take care
of her like he's got proposed to her Wow
show of hands Taylor Swift this high
sometime great evening [ __ ] no I don't
know she's hot oh my god
I'd say sometimes it depends it depends
I'm never seeing her hat I have seen her
not ugly though yeah yeah maybe that's
what I'm trying to find of her lips
she's a cute little girl yeah this is
not sex appeal yeah like she's cute
she's not if Ariana Grande looked a
little bit older I was a little more
voluptuous and not so like really pretty
she's very very pretty but she looks
like the 12 year old that never got
older her face is really pretty but she
has the body of a ten-year-old boy yeah
yeah her face looks young woman she
looks like a teenager
Ariana's face just like a beautiful
she's a very pretty face she does but I
agree with tip that she doesn't look
like a woman yes she looks like she's
like it's beautiful she's got great
features but she still looks like a
beautiful little girl yeah I think
without them don't even include the body
to her she's the epitome of cute yeah so
she's not pretty her face
we're not disagreeing like sexy like hot
is yeah you're right it has sex appeal
yeah but then I also use hot and like
just in good-looking too so that's why
maybe we'll think gorgeous and hot every
yeah
okay that makes well I had a teacher
that look like ariana grande that I
really wanted this match okay so and now
I've grown atmosphere is the best policy
sometimes so when I say I'm like I'll
shoot allows me that teacher yeah yeah
so anyway this dude here apparently he
didn't even get caught he was picked up
by police and that's when he just start
blabber map mouthing just saying like it
was to be famous I still I still has
money he wants to be famous exact I
thought it was about sixteen hundred
dollars over the fence that's it how
much money that woman is worth he went
to his words women that's not even
enough to buy her a purse her [ __ ]
long cost more that [ __ ] yeah what bank
the he robbed to get $1,600 my bag just
made it withdraw
there's probably more money to ATM than
$60 yeah yeah true and how did he rob it
oh maybe he robbed his own bank account
yeah he made a withdrawal he overdrafted
himself on that exactly that's so funny
yeah so here's the dude where's Taylor
Swift live Calabasas well the one that
you went to was in Rhode Island one of
her multiple properties I'm well I'm
pretty sure she has multiple properties
you know what if I ever become mega rich
he doesn't look crazy like he looks like
you living out creep like he'd make your
coffee at Starbucks like you his eyes
[ __ ] freaked me out though I won't
say this though that's more he does look
like he smells because he has that extra
sweaty long shirt Nick you know that's
true his body heat stretched it out
exactly got rosy cheeks and rosy cheeks
makes anything look in him he looks like
Santa Claus before he turned his life
around but his eyes and the smartdrive
if I was ever that [ __ ] rich though I
wouldn't put anything in my name I would
just have everybody else vibe
in property for at you nobody's gonna
find out where I'm at ever but they do
man you see how people are like you put
a hog girl that you've never said
anything about in a video they find out
where she went to elementary school what
her dog's name is they find everything
out there magical I don't know how to do
that everyone is active when you're
horny you become the world's best
detective that's yeah jealous or horny
yep damn you're so right thanks
[Music]